BOOM!!!!!!!
Hey guys, This week I figured out a way
to turn these cheep disposable water bottles
into super awesome exploding targets that go off with a sonic boom
I'm going to show you how to make them
These little "bottle blasters" are so simple to make and extremely gratifying to use for target practice
because when they get hit... They let out a sonic boom that sounds like gunshot and rocks your world!
The best part is, they are relatively safe to handle and practically free to make
All you need to get started is a tubeless tire valve, a one and a half inch steel end cap, and an empty water bottle.
You can see these valves are one and a quarter inch long, and I got this pack of 2 for about three dollars at a local auto parts store.
All you need to do is drill a 5/16th inch hole right into the center of the bottle cap.
So once you get your hole drilled out, you might just want to use a pair of pliers to clean out any excess there, get that hole about as clean and smooth as possible.
This will give you a little space to pull the valve through, if you grip onto it with a pair of pliers and tug
it should lock into the neck and create an airtight seal
Now the next step is to drill a half inch hole right into the center of this steel plug.
So let's go ahead and do that next.
Okay, so now we've got our finished valve assembly, as well as a half inch hole drilled into our steel cap.
The only thing we need to do now, is bring the two together.
Now to make that happen, just take the tip of your valve and stick it into the center of the hole
Lock onto the threads of your valve with your pair of pliers and give it a little tug
And you should fell the valve pop right into place
And it will hold securely into the end cap
And that right there my friends is pretty much it!
Super low cost and easy to make, and now to add the exploding target, you need to screw a water bottle into place and go pump it up
Let's test this thing out
Now at this point, you can pump up these bottles with a bike pump
and they will be ready to go, but just to take things to the next level
I created some of these templates on photoshop that you can have for free
Simply cut them out and wrap them around the bottle and you can see it give them a whole different look
with a professional looking built in target
How cool is that?
Simply take something like a bike pump, and attach it to the valve on the bottom
And we are going to pump this up to about 50 - 60 psi
but you don't want to a lot higher than that
Not with a water bottle
You can see, right between about 55 and 60 psi, the bottle starts crackling
and it starts changing shape as well
You don't really want to get it too much more full than that
This one's ready to blow up
Shon: God!
Grant: What would you compare that to, a gunshot?
Shon: That was louder than a gunshot, that was like...
Shon: at sonic boom, it was... I don't know, oh my god
Grant: Now just for fun, I went down to the dollar store and found one of these plastic sand castles
that I tried using for a base
Which is not nearly as practical as using a steel end cap
but it is a lot more fun
Now if your planning on using something like a slingshot to set it off
what you really want to do is round up a bunch of pebbles like these
These ones have really sharp edges
That's going to be great for tearing open the skin of those bottles
Okay, so apparently rocks and slingshots have no problems taking out these targets
So just for fun, we are going to try blowguns next
Wooh, that was amazing
Now if you want to take things to the next level, you can stop by the dollar store and pick up
a pack of side walk chalk, like these
And if you crush them up into a fin powder, and load those into the bottles
and when you hot the target
It explodes into a cool colorful cloud of dust
How cool is that?
Alright guys, so in conclusion, for very little effort and very little money
you can make your self some really awesome exploding targets
and the best part is, all your targets are free
all you need to do is find some cheep plastic water bottles, which i am sure you have
Just keep in mind that when these explode, they sound like gunshots in the neighborhood.
So just make sure your on good terms with your neighboors
Well, thats it for this video guys. Let me know what you would use these exploding targets for
in the comments below
and I will look for you in the next project video. I'll talk to you then
I think I got my phone a little bit too close to that shot
Thats a lot of chalk dust